[Music]
it's problems of resources,
that is to say that when we have had a municipal police force
for years we have
in fact an increase in insecurity in our
municipalities an increase in violence is
not new in fact it's growing but
it's not new and therefore we
need more means the good news and
I'm a I'm a
positive person the good news is that we
have to seize the  the opportunity of precisely
this increase in competence of this
increase in how to say municipal police officers
who did not exist before
so we have a lot of municipal police officers
now we also have
video surveillance we have
significant resources so we must use them  we
also need more agility and then
also give
the same weapons quite simply when we
get down to business we
really have to give the same weapons so to
our municipal police officers as the
national police officers and then we
also waste a lot of time  I
believe that security concerns
everyone there is no corporatism so
we are all together
municipal police and national police to
ensure the security of the country it is
extremely serious what happened
what are you  have precisely
because this meeting is over and
what could you have said to the
president did the president
himself make proposals so the
president listens listens a lot in fact
he has a he has a great  used to this
kind of exercise I also came
to the big debate so it's good to
give us the floor I hope it's not
just a communication exercise and
unfortunately I'm afraid I think we
really have to  actions
concrete actions to help us in the
short term we will not be able to solve
the fundamental problem of our society
because we really have a
fundamental problem in our society but on
short term progress we are really
waiting for us  the mayors of
fairly strong decision-making and we cannot always say
that there are social problems in
the neighborhoods etc. we have already done
a lot of things in these neighborhoods there
so we must also restore authority
give the mayors more means to the
police  municipalities simply so
that we can defend ourselves in my
municipality for two days I was alone there
were no national police officers
there were no firefighters because
the firefighters can only intervene
if the police  national security secures their
intervention yet I had
municipal police officers who could
secure firefighters and well no I
have no right to do that so then
there were two things first and it's
still the world to  upside down it was the
municipal police who defended the
police station which was attacked
with mortars so you see
it's really the world upside down so
we can clearly see that in fact the means we
have  mis are of course interesting but we
were on our own of course when we
saw this attack on the police station we
defended the police station but you
see it's still very symbolic
and I myself was the victim of a
charge  at some point in one of the
neighborhoods of my city I had a
municipal policeman who was injured on those
famous evenings when we were alone he was
injured
he was lowered
and so I ran I ran and
I really thought I was going to have a big
problem because here he is I
ran away the policeman the municipal police vehicle
was hit and I
was really worried about for us
for the policemen and we don't have the  above
in fact so I have a cat in the throat
here I
am I am mayor of the city
of herblay-sur-seine so in the
Val-d'Oise it is a city of 32000
inhabitants so here is our name Philippe
Philippe  roller can you
call then
recognized they took
you because at the college
here it was not the case it was not the case
good they did not recognize me on the other hand
when they saw the police vehicle
municipal arrive that's where they
charged in fact he wanted to kill
police officers
at the town hall or not they did not
attack the town hall so but of course
with everything that happened to my
colleagues we are worried in s  worried and
also here are in any case police weapons
our municipal police officers are armed but
these are weapons which do not have the
same performance as the
Macron national police today I am not saying that except
that he has accustomed us to  that during the
health crisis that's there was
during the yellow vests there are
always debates etc but behind
are there really
concrete things that will come out that's
our our concern
I'm not  convinced I only ask
to be because the hour is serious we
have to take decisions and
not big words not big
things we have to we have to deal with the
fundamental problem but that will have to be
years because it will not be able to be
treated now but here I think that
the Republic is in danger we have to
sit around a table and
that we are allowed to have a
greater agility an agility agility
efficiency  the
municipal police, for example,
cannot go to other
territories, you see, it's a lot of
things like that that make us
less efficient, thanks to you, it's
over, it's ending
[  Music]
15000 inhabitants so
y okay
you feel how convinced this
meeting is just words from
the President of the Republic
it was important that the President of the
Republic comforts the seas who have
been on the front line
in  on the other hand, what emerges at this
stage is really not much, we do
not have the feeling that the government is
preparing measures since we have no
course of action from the President of
the Republic, we have had many
observations, many diagnoses which  have
been asked by colleagues, however
for the moment there is no measure
announced and we remain in particular on
our end when the situation is
particularly serious for security
but also on the social bond on the
policy of the city that  was said a lot
and by all the mayors
present and we really have answers
for the moment of his it's good not there
in your city what
happened can you remind us a little
bit about this  which had two
particularly very difficult nights with
the shares of fire in the town hall
which is a building classified as a
historic monument and which today is out
of use and we have damage
of around 7 million euros in damage in
the municipality is the one year of
investment budget here and a
rather violent minority and which causes this damage
there today we need other
answers we need means to
repair this damage and we are not going there
now  now you are waiting
for things to be put in place in
fact and that after the speech we are
waiting for very concrete answers
both to repair the damage that has been
caused and it is not the local elected officials who
are responsible for these tensions and
its damage and we are waiting for measures
on the policy of the city since we have
had no direction from the
government for too long the
Borlo plan which had been a follow-up which
had been totally lived a
first class funeral and today  I do
n't know if President Macron wants to
resuscitate him, we wo
n't have to, we absolutely need
additional resources for education,
for justice, for the police, for
sport, for culture, confronted with
young people who today
have what as a model  cultural
to seek branded clothing
to seek recognition
through an existence made up of logos and
things of this type or do we
manage to build through
popular education through
national education a  youth who are
emancipated and a youth who are
able to take their destiny in hand and
the collective destiny too, so there you have it, I do
n't have to either I play the baby with
wine Certainly not all young people are involved in
delinquency in this way  or in
violence but we must also be interested
in those who today take action
without any brakes automatically
quickly it's it's a failure to say that
as a failure thank you very much
please
and the  surname bac bacteria
from Neuilly-sur-Marne in
Seine-Saint-Denis what did you
expect from this meeting then
sorry LR what did you expect
from this meeting then
were you  satisfied not at all me
I had not come to see the
school nurse or a psychologist there we were
in the middle of group therapy after
three hours there is no answer
given by the President of the
Republic me j  I was still expecting the
President of the Republic to give a
vision a course to tell us how we
got out of it
and and move forward today we
said absolutely nothing so I am
extremely disappointed in addition to  be exhausted
because we've been
sleeping two hours a night for five days doing
patrols in the city to try
the national police the municipal police
in my city the 7
municipal police cars were burned the
housing department has  was burnt the
media library was burned down the tobacco bar
was burned finally here it is a
terrible situation and today I
have no answer I am really
sorry and I regret it terribly
it was it was
pure  communication say that we have
received 200 m what is coming out of it
what is the direction that
is given
I do not know and here I am disappointed
tired of this situation we will continue
and  we will continue to move forward on
our own but really I had not
come to see the psychologist nor attended
group therapy
there might be announcements but
in the future today it was
to listen to the mothers what  'they had to
say to ask when we can listen
but there is an exchange which must
take place there after three hours
the President of the Republic
said nothing nothing not a word so here it is
extremely
I  came to fire the alarm room
I came to say that we needed
strong means to send a strong message
to offenders I
also came to ask for a stronger legal framework
for cities that have  need to be
reinforced in particular to
allow their municipal police
to be properly equipped to have
drones which can intervene
today we are putting our lives in
danger we are being eliminated everywhere in France
to go on rounds to
save what  can be saved to
save our town halls and today we are
under-equipped we are on our own we
are alone and so here I am disappointed will
the violence continue
last night in your municipality no
it was  that was the tension to lower
the media library was insane a kindergarten
also here so the situation is
rounds in the city we make
candles until 5 6 a.m.
and today I came to hear the
President of the Republic also
to listen of course but to give a vision
a framework here because in fact after
3 hours there is strictly no word which
was announced by Presidents of the
Republic none I had not come to
attend a therapy  group
today were in
group therapy and a young person I am
extremely disappointed in addition to being expressed
by the situation
no I think that the role of the President of
the Republic is to listen, of course,
but  to give a course first of all a vision
of the situation today I
had nothing nothing and and me it worries me for the
future you know when we are alone with
our little arms to fight against
people who never want  terror
in our neighborhood we need to be
and to have the feeling that there is
someone with us who is in the state by
our side so the state on a daily basis I
feel it with the national police
firefighters who are doing great
work by our side but I
also had to take to the Elysée the expectation
of having a cap a vision of the solutions
of the tracks less that would be given and
today we leave with nothing so here we go
I am going to work because we have
a lot if you have physically
why I would like the Head of
State to give a reinforced framework to our
cities so that they allow our
municipal police to huddle properly
with very concrete equipment  with
LBDs which have a better range
because today we can only shoot at
7 meters when the police can
be at 40 meters so 7 meters you are
in contact I also ask what
drones we are  make it possible to
identify football movements how to
organize for the municipal police
in my city I was the second city in
France to set up a
curfew from the first evening it allowed us
to limit the damage because
that  allowed us to immediately identify
the groups that were beginning to
form and to intervene over the longer
term I I think and I
say it as calmly as
myself I am of Iranian origin I
think that we  has a real subject on whatever
the fact of making a nation the fakes that at
school can teach all the
children in all the neighborhoods how
we make a nation and today we do
n't do it me I here it is c  is
something
unfortunately today we are in
a hurry I would like it to be the base
there to be placed on the sea because otherwise
we will see each other again in a few years
with a magnificent idea and we will not have
the concentrated strength  three years of mandate
we will all have already lived in these three
years of mandate I hang on it is
over for my city for my inhabitants
but which will help you to follow
obviously we are here it goes
through our minds but we are we  is focused
on our our function on the fact
that we must call it depends on
the general interest we have a
public service mission we must be able to ensure
for all the inhabitants who have
trusted us so we advance me I
advance it with  closed determination
in English
I did not understand
just excuse me that when we
possibly take 400 interventions we
answer something like that you are
the air it is Renaissance now no
honestly there we are mobilized on the
ground I was elected by  all the
inhabitants I am the mayor of all the
inhabitants regardless of their
political coloring really sir mayor so
you speak a little English ask yourself
a question either so yes
darkochine Z was hte and the
surname bacteria made akhi to RS
Neuilly-  sur-Marne in Seine-Saint-Denis
thank you very much is it possible
Raphaël assassin who came all
year with us ok
09 03
we can ask you a little question
in English thank you
[Music]
at the beginning simply  to say thank you
for being there thank you to our police officers
thank you to us complicated and the floor is
over no answer we could have
waited for Satan because after
a few questions a few
interventions there is an answer in any
case a few lines
at the end  of the police
[Music]
which allow things to move forward
I tell myself that I can
listen well but when we exchange with
someone we listen and we respond to
something today there are strictly
nothing at the end of  4 a.m.
but for me it's December what are
you going to
say when you get back and what are you
going to do personally in your
town hall when you go back if he's
outside are still performing this evening
like the others  we will be mobilized on
the ground to patrol with with the
municipal agents the elected officials who are
mobilized I will not communicate on this
meeting if there was exactly no
interest and I am really
nonsense Thanks to YOU ​​have a nice day see you
soon thank you goodbye
[Music]
you want more I have the poor
I am nice
of the meeting with the 241 saying
Emmanuel Macron has turned into a
school nurse we are not in
group therapy he makes the same
message in  English at AP that's very good
there on the other hand you see you can put it if
you have it you can put the little Larose
AP like that it will do
I don't know if it's that's great thank you
in addition he has his little one well
infernal school communication thing
group therapy that's all words
are well weighed
33 34 years old
very well
[Music] [
Music]
[Laughs]
[Music]
for the moment
moreover it's true
no but it's true
3:20 p.m. ago
[Music]
that's why it's
not bad they're already out
if the mayor of Neuilly-Plaisance
thank you very much
[Music] [
Music]
ah here is the real international press
[Music]
degraded
OLE
[Music  ]
[Music]
I'm going to stay on TV in fact
it's a problem
I'm trying to go up
[Music]
[Applause]
and moreover
on
earth
so I never speak
and elsewhere  generally the third
I have a day soon
yes hello Yann Gallu mayor of Bourges
various left
I have Yann
left this meeting
listen first of all the President of the
Republic took the time to
listen to us it lasted more than three hours
all the seas who wanted it
wanted to express themselves
very clearly afterwards we are waiting to see
the rest he made announcements on an
emergency law to rebuild so that
is interesting,
in particular our municipal buildings which
have been extremely affected  he
also announced specific credits in
relation to the damage we had had he
announced work with insurance
so we will have in the
coming days how that translates then there
announced major projects
and what we felt that  he wanted to go
very quickly since he adores us it is
already to be made an appointment for the end of the
summer he also announced some
interesting things on the fact that he
proposed that the deadlines be reduced in
particular precisely to rebuild
the  a lot of damage that we have had
on our territories so that's it's
interesting now we're going to see
concretely we'll see concretely
what the consequences are he announced he
announced on this he illness he had he
had a comment  balanced on this
question there on the parents on the
parenting he said that we could not
I would say go to easy solutions
so we felt him measure on
this question there with of course the
will that the authority be reaffirmed
but also specific situations
a lot of mayors insisted for
example on the problems of
single parenthood compared to
parents so on that he was not I
would say he was he was measured on his
words there but not the seas he put he
brought into the debate in terms of
reflection he announced four or five
major projects and he said that there
was this question of parents there was
this question of
juvenile justice where he said he had  already where
he said that he had already acted in
relation to that the fundamental debate also that what
I felt and that we are
several mothers to have felt is
that he told us that the
financial means were already there  and that in
France efforts had already been
made for town halls etc and for
local authorities, but we are on the
ground very clearly after two years
of covid after inflation and well we have
real funding problems
so there we can  - to be a small
divergence with the President of the
Republic
it is necessary I do not say that it is necessary to
sanction the parents I do not say that it I do
not say that it should not be done
either I say that I say that this
solution there  it must be after a
reflection there are sometimes parents who
must be sanctioned but we must
not be caricatural on this question
there the parents are not on the same
footing of equality that he reminded us we do
not grow up the same in  all the
families so we will of course have to
make proposals on this but
they cannot be captured
thank you
goodbye
[Music]
everyone is ready the umbrella is
there everything is fine do we have to
sanction the parents  as the
publicity seems to want to think, so fortunately the debates
did not relate only to this
question which had indeed been
the subject of an announcement by the President last
evening, we discussed much
broader issues on the question of  the
sanction of the parents is a
gimmicky measure it's like the business of
video games and social networks
nothing will happen basically and especially in a
few years we will have to
declare riots again to organize
sessions like the one  this
collective psychotherapy offered by the Elysée if we are
content with slogans like that of
sanctioning the parents
collective psychotherapy that's what you experienced
yes it was a bit of a meeting of
anonymous mayors you see there were very
many of us there  speech was distributed
randomly we will say and
finally apart from
an extremely limited introduction
by the president who had been indicated
to only want to listen to the nerves a
somewhat longer conclusion where he
made the litany here again of billions
and investments of the  State
the president appeared to be very
satisfied with his policy in reality the
city the various ministries which
act little to question a
rather weak capacity to see the way in which
one could
fundamentally transform what generates
regular crises in the suburbs I
indicated me  in my speech that
the subject was less an umpteenth
suburban plan of measures to
satisfy the nerves but the will or
not of the French State to break up the
ghettos of the rich and to break up the
ghettos of the poor to organize the
diversity at the scale of each building at
the scale of each city it was a
meeting for nothing
[Music]
yes I'm not the only one you know there are
seas that have not even come
that have not  took the trouble to come and
listen to the President of the Republic and
there are many who were invited
who did not come today because
we have been alerting for years and
still a month ago you have a
platform of 30 mothers who have  say it's going to
blow up are you interested in the suburbs we
need an emergency plan and they have
n't had an answer you understand the
desperation when you constantly alert
you say the house is going to burn and
it burns and the fireman  arrives
telling you hey there was a
problem the electrical panel which was
not up to standard you know for years we've been
telling you and he's telling you we're going to
change two or three cables a fuse or
two and then everything will be fine no we  we are
waiting for structural changes which do not
concern the
suburbs it is not by intervening
only in the suburbs through
the policy of the city that we will
get there it is an intervening on the scale
of the country everywhere  where we have mayors who
do not agree to build
social housing to take part
of our miseries and our
collective misfortunes and well we generate the
conditions for the renewal of riots
and difficulties and we can
bail out the bathtub with a  teaspoon
but if each time they come to
give us Grosso dos we will never get there
regardless of the means made
available which are already insufficient
I felt no determination either to
provide us with sufficient means to
deal with the emergency or to  intervene on the
substance of the problem to eradicate the
ghettos of the poor did you
take it by
I believe he had I believe that the
President we had no ambition to
convince us he understood that he was facing
him  disillusioned mothers to whom you
can't play the flute to
convince them so he was mainly there to, in
my opinion, announce to the media that he brought
together the mayors less to
convince them to mobilize them for you it's
just an effect of  announcement finally just an
effect I did not expect much from it
but I measured that indeed there
were no concrete measures to be
expected in the short term I
deeply believe that the President of the
Republic who is at the  beyond him what he
surrounds do not understand anything about what is
happening that they did not see coming
while the thermometer is indicating the
fever and that they do not know how to
solve the problem basically
if they are  ready to engage in a cycle of
work to reflect together we can
find a little hope I am waiting
for him to give tangible signs
follow up on this meeting so
he has not announced anything in terms of
continuing the dialogue me I  I
asked explicitly in my
speech we have the Borlo report 6 months of
work of hundreds of mothers
thousands of people in the suburbs
of associations who have worked we have the
report of urban France we have
proposals from the Association of  mayors
of France local elected officials and actors
in the field in the suburbs where making a
diagnosis offers solutions that
sometimes diverge but there are
solutions on the table what I
asked in conclusion is that they
provide the means  Minister for the
City by political means because in
terms of political authority, at least
we can say that the Minister
for the City weighs nothing against Bercy,
the financial means of course to be
able to undertake this work on the
long time and take emergency measures
obviously you have to treat the fever
because it is there with doliprane
and when you have a country and
neighborhoods with multiple bills, a doliprane will
not cure the bills you have to
find much more
daring solutions  who will come across the
country not the chain of
popular neighborhoods change the situation we feel that
it's nothing is true anyway the
next few years will take place finally
that's it I gave him almost the
date in conclusion  from my speech
he will perhaps still be present from the
Republic after the crisis of the
yellow vests the explosion of the suburbs he will
perhaps not deplore a new one
in three years at the next
police blunder at the next generating event
there  has no authority problem according to you there
are 1000 authority problems in the
country of course you know when the
unions mobilize for months
against the pension reform I cite
this example there and who get nothing
the feeling that  'he loves you to the rest of the
population is that
collective mobilization democracy
usually regular social relations
are useless and that
everything must be broken and after authority
obviously the authority of local elected officials authority
of the President of the Republic
itself the authority of the masters etc is
in question because the Republic it is
a promise freedom equality fraternity
when this promise it is betrayed what
incarnates the Republic no longer have
any authority any more any credibility
it  there is a controversy it talks about
something else about the kitty made for the
police we have people from here do you
think that there were other reactions
I don't know if you are I
remember at the time of  the crisis of the
yellow vests of a kitty which aimed
to support it was a gesture my memory
is good boxer who attacked
police officers and very legitimately the
government denounced what was an
immoral kitty which came to take
charge of the legal costs it
possible conviction of a container
today we have a police officer who is
under investigation for intentional homicide
intentional homicide it is extremely
serious and who is imprisoned, that is to say
that he is imprisoned and we accept and
tolerate that  the jackpot launched by a
far-right activist
collects more than a million euros and we
accept that it takes place before our
eyes you do not have a single
conviction of a minister when they
were unanimous there is  barely 4 years
to condemn the first pot
against a yellow vest it's immoral you
see the authority it is also embodied
when we are constant in these decisions
not when we are in the condemnation
when it comes to a vest  yellow and in
tolerance when it comes to a who
is indicted for homicide and you
still feel like the
President you listened to
suburban [ __ ] from hard places the
president staged the  listening to the
seas he staged it for you
journalists so the mayors
spoke not all but a number
of them I think he listened
carefully he took notes but I
think that  'he absolutely needed
this image
of the nerves gathered around him if he
sincerely wanted to listen to them
would have done so 2 years ago we have, I
repeat, constantly multiplied the
requests for meetings they made us set
appointments for two years
that have not honored what is the
height of contempt on the part of the
national power and well this contempt in the end they
generate frustration and
despair thank you very much thank you
ah he understood that on the  Borlo report
he had succeeded in winning unanimous support
against him from the left and
right mayors who had contributed to its
drafting
not either he was much more
moderate much more he drew the
consequences of his first mistake but
we are far from the mea  culpa and above all he did
not propose a method to resume the
construction of the report in the water but you
felt it completely out of step
with the situation
you know the President of the Republic
when we all had
sleepless nights to go and protect our
equipment and trying to put out the fire
in the literal sense he was at the
Elton John concert
I think that illustrates quite well the
lag of our rulers in relation
to the reality on the ground
manage with that be
careful it's going to fall
women
who are  actually went out
it's good
[Music]
it was just image politics on
the part of the President of the Republic I
think that we will see the consequences especially
because there was I believe a  quality
of listening all the mayors in their
diversity were able to express myself
I insisted a lot on two subjects
that are particularly close to him,
it is to reaffirm the role of
mediators in the districts
in the national education system to
be in contact the  as close as possible
to the kids from secondary school
because these are
privileged opportunities to be in contact with
young people and then the mediators who
have done, we have not said enough about the
events that we have experienced,
we  there have been mediators present in the
neighborhoods and what I asked the
President of the Republic is a
request also which is
also presented by the deputy Patrick Vignal is
that there is a professionalization of the
role of  mediators in the neighborhoods
it's a real job that deserves
real training and real
recognition of the role that can be
played within the framework of what is called
the security cotilium so that I can be
sure of having been j  I heard in
any case don't listen to the President of the
Republic and then a second request
which he answered a little is
on the fact that today the politics
of the city is a stack of
politics c  It is an
administrative thing that is
increasingly difficult to digest to understand
for mayors for elected officials in the field
it is time for the State to give itself the
means of clarification and
readability President Macron has
increased the income on  a new state of
decentralization on a clarification
of competences between the various
actors and at the moment that we intend to
approach this subject there but we say to ourselves that
the site was was in progress he
insisted on the fact that the prefects
are on foot  work to analyze very
quickly the results of the
events that we have just experienced I
want to believe that we have been summoned to
the prefecture next Friday to
have a discussion with the prefect of
the Gironde and also he will announce to us
that as of the  at the end of the summer there will be a
new meeting with the mayors to
see that they were the first
decisions that could be taken in the
light of these analyzes
financially the parents from the
first impression of the child I think
there  no we have to stop coming
out with gadget solutions we have to
first discuss with the parents there are
36,000 situations of parents there are some
who are overwhelmed more or less
voluntarily but we can't me I
think it's  these solutions snap
fingers demago and unsuitable I think
that's not how we will get out
of this bad situation I think we
must first discuss with the
parents we must restore the human I
believe that  we have terribly dehumanized
our relations in all of them in all the
neighborhoods you have to introduce the human
if you if you don't do it
you condemn yourself to
acts of this nature which can take
precedence so I think that it  you have to
discuss first before saying me, I'm giving it back by a
miracle, it's the sanction, but I
think for the sanction there are other
stages than these stages, you have to
discuss it with the interests, some
mothers, they say that the president  Macron
was totally out of step with the
situation in the country and what has happened
in recent days I think that
many elected officials have the disadvantage of
not having been elected local and mayor
because you know before being a mother I
did not imagine how much the function
of mayor puts you in a
privileged relationship if it will not always
feel privileged but in
any case in a privileged relationship with
the inhabitants and to be in direct contact
I am not sure that at the  top of the state
this privileged relationship it exists
all the time an example the
Borlo report a lot of mayors talked about the
report
being highly regarded at the top of the state
and yet the bolo report had an
American advantage it was a report
that was  made by a local elected official an
experienced mayor and I proposed
solutions on the ground and several mayors
and several of my colleagues talked
about we will talk about the report jerk off even if
I think it is it is essential
it's true  that since then there has not been the
same type of proposal exercise
coming from the field I think that we must
draw inspiration from this type of method
solution will not come from above more
exactly from here it will come from the
field
I am not interpreted as such yes
perhaps at the level of communication
but I think that here I think that he
heard many mayors who spoke about
flying reports it is surprising
because it is a report that is quite
old but which is still in the
still in the drawers
not with yet another plan that we are going to
solve
we are not going to reinvent the wheel this
report it deserves it deserves it deserves
to exist a lot of mothers they are
referents so I  think it would be nice
if at the top on a kitty made for
the policeman who is in prison you
feel about that it's
political politics honestly I'm
not interested that I think that there is
a very strong will of the  part of
the extreme right to want to recover this
movement I think it has to be said it
has to be said loud and clear and I think
that we all have an interest in being extremely
suspicious of this
indecent indecent recovery of  the extreme right
super thank you sir
seriously
when we are together
but you talk you don't talk to me like
that
urgently to be able to have
funding to rebuild a certain
number of things it's a good idea
on the rest he told us  we're going to
meet again in September and we're going to
discuss again because there were about
ten points that you
know your remarks on
migration may have very much appreciated but
no, but you know there are a certain
number of  wed who are first time fake asses
when they tell you in
private